transformed into a human plant hybrid
Pamela Isley's linked with the green was
empowered by mankind's mistakes an
unrelenting enforcer atomic poison ivy
lashes out with roots and razor-sharp
thorns
her passive is called toxic growth if
she has taken no damage after a short
time atomic poison ivy gains a shield
enemies who use basic attacks on the
shield are marked with toxic growth
which grants her skills additional
effects in addition her damage based
skills mark enemies with toxic growth if
an enemy is already marked with toxic
growth the mark is consumed and grants
additional effects to the skill poisoned
earth deals area of effect power damage
poisoning enemies and applying toxic
growth if already applied toxic growth
is instead consumed and the skill deals
significant additional power damage
bramble rapture roots a target and deals
power damage if the target has toxic
growth bramble rapture consumes the
effect to boost her move speed wall of
thorns raises a barbed wall that slows
enemies and deals power damage over time
targets with toxic growth are silenced
and the mark is consumed her ultimate
secrets of the forest surrounds atomic
poison ivy and a fog that provides
nearby allies with stealth and power
armor additionally enemies within the
fog are marked with toxic growth every
second
when jungling put a point into bramble
rapture before maxing out poisoned earth
and wall of thorns poisoned earth and
its toxic growth damage boost offers a
fast and effective jungle while bramble
raptures root and wall of thorns slow
creates strong early ganks when coming
out of the jungle drop a wall of thorns
to start a powerful combo follow up with
bramble rapture consuming toxic growth
for boosted speed and then use poisoned
Earth's to deal devastating damage
secrets of the forest is great for
initiating teamfights or as an escape so
try saving it for when your team is
ready prioritize artifacts that give
additional health armor cooldown
reduction and will two great choices are
metallus heart and fragment of Mo go to
complement her enforcer role consider
Abin SURS Lantern for extra will
allowing you to use a crowd control more
often and granting power damage at
higher tiers for even more power damage
the star heart and fatalities energy
lands are strong options atomic poison
ivy's x-ray vision is on a shorter
cooldown giving you a safer margin to
see champions and stealth entangle foes
with toxic entrapment as atomic poison
ivy
you